i'm going to talk about multicalibration
universal adaptability and causality
and usually if this was a conference and
when you put such a title then the next
natural line is to say
during the talk i will explain all of
these terms right but this is a workshop
so you're here to work
so instead what i'll do is i'll tell you
a little bit about multi calibration but
guy did most of the work for me
and i'll talk mostly about universal
adaptability
and you can explain to me causality
after
so that's the plan
most of what we're going to talk about
is this work uh
on universal adaptability with michael
king christoph curran chaffee goldwater
4k
a quarter and we have here
uh
christoph michael
and shafi
and but
christoph and michael wave
that kind of
led this project felt very strongly that
we should give the
new
talent some exposure so here i am
and
i'm mostly going to talk about that and
talk about some work in progress and
then i'll add with some
musings on of my own which nobody is
responsible for
not necessarily even i
okay so what what are we going to talk
about
we're going to talk about this problem
of adapting
a study a research
from a target distribution from source
distribution to a target distribution
and i'm going to start by describing
the uh
the most common approach paradigm
for this which is through a
propensity scoring
um
and then i moved to this new approach
kind of an alternative paradigm
that we can call universal adaptation
and the motivation would be
um
when we want to talk about adapting from
one source to multiple targets
i think we'll be motivated beyond that
and then um
we'll see how to so we'll describe this
notion
and then we'll see how multicalibration
that we already heard about that comes
from the literature about fairness
and can help us get this strong notion
and finally i'll
remember that i was invited to a
workshop on causality
and i'll talk a little bit about things
that are perhaps even more related to
causality mostly about
um
the way propensity scores are used to
estimate the treatment effect
and then
then i'll get my
to my
musings about multicalibration causality
which can be completely off or by the
end of this workshop we can have a
formal result so we'll see
okay good
um so what is this problem of
generalization
we have a study in
some source distribution this study we
have
covariates features for many individuals
and the corresponding outcomes for them
and we want to translate it to some
target distribution which may be
different
and where we have the
individuals but we don't have the
outcomes
you can think about the source as for a
survey let's say phone survey that
only uh
reaches people with cell phones that are
willing to answer surveys
who are these people i don't know
and then perhaps uh t is for the true
population we want to
to actually study
alternatively yes can be for stanford a
study in stanford hospital
and we want to apply it in a different
population perhaps
for tea the bronx
hospital
that's the level of creativity we have
here
so
so that's the setting
and let's give us a few
notations
don't really
going to use them too much but still
x
is the um
[Music]
the range of covariates features of
individuals for every individual we
collect a lot of features
you know i know we tell you how many
features there could be
in their talk later
and then there is an outcome that we
want to predict
and
that's the outcome
of interest this talk it could be
a real outcome between zero and one but
you can also think about just a binary
outcome
had the heart attack didn't have a heart
attack
z is the source versus target population
and we'll think about it
as a random variable which is strange i
mean for me coming from
3s thinking about it as a random
variable is a bit strange so
uh for for those that find it strange
think about defining and
distinguishability
by thinking about two distribution and
you flip the coin giving you one or the
other so think about z as a uniform just
a uniform bit telling you if you're in
the source or the target
and what we want to estimate is the
expectation of the outcome
over the target
but the information we have is in the
source
this is the very
most basic statistics we may care about
but um
[Music]
what we're talking about will apply for
more sophisticated statistics
okay so that's the setup
what are the key assumptions that will
let us do that
the first assumption is conditional
independence
where we're saying that y the outcome
we're predicting
and z telling us if we're in the source
or the target our independent
conditioned on x
this essentially says that what we're
trying to predict
is the same
the kind of the relation between the
covariates and the
outcome is the same in the source and
the
target otherwise
perhaps you cannot learn from the source
anything about the target
solution
is different than the target
distribution so i don't know what's
biased or not but they're
right that's a good uh
observation and then
[Music]
yeah i'm not sure if you need
that strongly but but that's that's i
guess what the assumption says
and we talked about uh when we talked
about treatment effect we'll actually
talk about things where there is a
reaction
and
and then we
we want sufficient representation so we
want it to be the case that
no large subpopulation
in the target
is completely unrepresented in the
source
everything has to be at least slightly
represented so we have information about
this application otherwise
we have no chance of of learning what
how to deal with this population
kind of should we already kind of
connect us to a little bit of fairness
because one issue is under
representation of
example solutions
so both of these are required
for our approach universal adaptability
but it's also required for
the prevalent approach of a propensity
scoring
and um
in fact it's kind of required
to some extent for for saying anything
unless you're making other assumptions
that may be as strong or
strong
and so what is this propensity score
we model these are this is a way to
model the shift
in the distribution between the source
and the target
and so odds of sampling a given
individual x from the source versus the
odds of sampling it in the target
kind of hinting on on what guys
talked about the meaning of
individual probabilities that's
completely unclear what this means but
we will not talk about it i'll be happy
to talk
offline
but the way i mean what this supposed to
be
is that
a
condition on a particular
individual
what's the probability
that we are in the source
and that's why we thought about this
kind of thing about
and that you're sampling either from the
source or from the target with
the same probability and then given that
you saw an individual what's the
probability from the source
um
if it was the same distribution this
would be half right
but
um not the same situation
what we wanted to to be is that this
perpendicular scores is bounded away
from zero
and because
if it's zero it means that this
individual is completely
not represented
in the source
and therefore we cannot learn about it
in the target
this is a requirement about individuals
we talked about subpopulation we can
extend it
just know that um
one minus this uh
this term esti
is the probability that it's from the
target and what we're really interested
in is the ratio
what the probability that it's in target
over what it's what's
the probability that it's in the source
what's the relation between them
and yeah good
questions
so how do we use that and
under this assumption of conditional
independence
you can learn
this simple statistic that we talked
about
in the target
by kind of weighing uh differently
the the outcomes in the source
so
[Music]
you can think about it as re-weighing a
y or you can think about it as
re-weighing exits
you can even think about it as you given
a sample of the source you can kind of
create with these weights a sample from
the target and then you can learn
there so what is this paradigm you
estimate these properties scores
using unlabeled samples from the source
and the target
and then now that you have those
this properties score
and you're going to
um
to do this three way
in a sense as i said you can think about
it as creating
the target distribution from the source
distribution
that's that's the problem that many of
you probably know very well
the thing is that we don't have this
propensity scores
so what do we do here we do what we do
everywhere
and
we
try to learn it from some class so think
about sigma as a class
of potentially
potential propensity scores
and this class has to be bounded
complexities of bonded complexity so you
have a chance of learning
and now what we're going to do is
instead of these properties scores we're
going to
try to fit try to learn
some sigma that would represent for us
and the properties score and then we
will do the re-weighing
with sigma playing the role of the
property score so that's now we have the
entire paradigm
good
i'm happy
so here are reasons not to be happy
and
one is that the assumptions may not
always hold
unfortunately we can't do anything about
it either
the other one is that the true
compensation score may not be in this
sigma maybe even far from sigma
our theorem say nothing about this case
but there is some reason to think that
perhaps we can still do something
interesting in this case
i won't talk about it
very much
but what we really want the real
challenge that
motivates this work
is that
when you have when you do the training
when you come up with this propensity
score you need labeled examples from the
source and the target
and this may be unrealistic in several
cases so here are some cases in which
it's unrealistic
first it could be that we want to apply
the same study from stanford in many
hospitals
and so what are we going to do we're
going to do all this sharing
with every hospital which is costly and
we train for every a hospital
this is not
realistic other one is that perhaps
this distribution doesn't exist now we
want to apply this study for stanford in
five years
the population may change in five years
but we cannot
at the time of training take this
non-existent distribution into account
finally kind of coming from privacy
kind of perspectives there are
limitations of sharing information and
here we want to share a lot of
information we want to share the
covariates of individuals
now this kind of motivates our
attempt to get into universal
adaptability i want to do something at
the source let's say it's stanford
that would somehow be universally
applicable to all these various targets
that's the motivation
that's the picture so now we don't have
a single target we have many targets
and the way i want to do this
kind of
adaptation is in a one-way manner
first i do some learning here in the
source
and then i send the outcome of this
study
to all these destinations to all these
targets and they could
take it from there
so i don't want this back and forth i
don't want information from the targets
to the source which means
that i can deal with targets that are
not known or perhaps not existing at the
time
what specifically is going to be yes
so under the assumption that the
population is independent from the
outcome given
covariates
why can't you just send
the
algorithm to the targets have them plug
in their covariates and what they get
out will be valid
oh i don't know whatever it is so
immediately i don't understand what it
is that you're producing so the
statistics which can still be very
different from the source
let's say i want to see what's the
expectation of a particular outcome it
can be very different in the source i
mean each one of the outcomes
so uh apparently all i wanted to do is
estimate some statistics
yeah i can't send just these statistics
right okay so observe that
what you're producing in the surf
population is not
an estimation or prediction of y given x
it's an aggregate of that so in fact
that's that's going to be our approach
instead of sending
a
value
so what is the outcome of this study
that i want i want some predictor
from any individual
and to the outcome
thing is that we don't have i mean the
true probabilities
and that's er and
so yeah if we had the true probabilities
it will be
the true predictor that really gives you
for every x
the expectation of y given x then it
would apply everywhere in the world
but we don't have it in a sense what we
want is a predictor that's still as good
so that's the challenge as good for
every target distribution
question
might be targeted
distribution doesn't have the
labels the study is done
for those people they have conducted it
and and that's where you have the label
examples the target only has unlabeled
examples
so somehow
and the thing is that perhaps even that
is going a little bit further
to your
question the approach of smos
minimization
is which is the standard things i want
to create this predictor by losing
immunization on the source
is very
tied to the distribution
when i try to minimize a loss on one
distribution
it can be give me a horrible predictor
for a different distribution
so somehow although i don't have the
target distribution i want to do
something in the source that would still
do well in all these target
distributions yes sorry this is kind of
a related question i think um
i i think i was confused because you
were saying the word study but you don't
mean someone did like a causal
experiment you mean that like they have
labeled data in the source we will talk
about uh i mean there are two things
that can create a predictor and also you
want potentially to look at treatment
effects and talk a little bit about
treatment effect
but here i'm just talking about
and
observations of the version of study
um
so we want to train a predictor which is
what much of what i said train the
predictor in the source
and so this only means that i need
labeled examples in the source
and then when i want to infer these
statistics or more sophisticated
statistics in the target
i'm going to
take the expectation of this predictor
in the target so in the target all i
need is
unlabeled examples from the target for
infrastructure i'm decoupling
what i need from the source and what i
need from the target
and the point is that unfortunately
predictors that are trained
on the source using the current
approaches of loss minimizations can be
very bad
on the target
and that's
that's where the challenge is
can it be obtained
and yes we are going to give this
universal adapter that's
due to frauke she found it
so
let me say a little bit about algorithm
furnace although i see that this is a
much more loaded topic than
so
i was worried that he'll get complaints
about not talking about causality
but in terms it was about algorithm
fairness but let me still
risk it but that's not the topic so
i'll try to be quick
so
um
the literature on algorithmic fairness
is trying to identify forms of unfair
discriminations
and then ways of addressing them
and
just say that
one of the confusion is that
and when people say okay i want to
obtain fairness
or i'm studying fairness or doing
something in fairness
is the thought that okay now my outcome
is going to be fair
and the issue is that nothing
is going to be fair
and therefore
we are trying to address
part of the problem and we're trying to
be very clear about what we are
addressing and what we're not addressing
that's kind of our approach
and but
if you want to get something that's
fair by any definition of fairness
then this kind of leads to all or
nothing approach which unfortunately
more often than not leads to nothing
than to all
because we can't get all
historic operation can manifest itself
in the data in different ways
under representation mislabeling missing
features
and the question is in which cases
unfair discrimination
through data can be addressed and in
each cases you can you need to say no i
can do nothing the data is too
problematic there's nothing to do
i i'm not allowing any kind of target
targeting
the point here
that in heterogeneous
population
sometimes some notions of fairness
actually can't remove promote accuracy
utility because they help identify
untapped potential
and because
inaccuracy can be a form of
discrimination not the only form of
discrimination but once we agree that
inaccuracy can be a way
to discriminate
then addressing inaccuracy could be also
um
one aspect of fairness
and there's also what guy said about
um if we want to
kind of improve towards the world as we
want it to be
we better understand what the world as
it is
and this is kind of this is the story
we're telling here
so multicalibration
um
because
like
as far as i understand you are assuming
that you're using the operational thing
to
obtain over the source population and
then if you try to
because obviously this is the
combination but if you were running a
randomized control trial
and trying to generalize that to other
populations
in this case would failures be a concern
as well
and
any kind of data that we have or study
that we have more information that we
gather
and
friends will still be concerned because
and whatever information we have doesn't
apply to every individual
right
from some
study that we have to other individuals
and and we are going to do it with
something that is somehow efficient
a model or or something even a model for
for treatment
and now the theory is and it's not
a
sporadic fear the fear is
that the model that you have to settle
but you can't you don't have
inflammation and you don't have
computational power to do something that
works for every individual
is going to sacrifice
some subpopulations for the benefit of
others
and we have it
in the example that
guy showed about this
equipment effect
predictors for uh
that are used in practicing healthcare
they are not equally accurate for
for all groups although
they're based on science
so
unless you have information about any
individual and can run a test about any
individual the casing the question still
remains what happens after
i mean
who are you sacrificing for me
so that's why
beyond problems in the data there is
additional discrimination that can
happen while training
i'm sorry maybe i can't see i don't
understand your definition of what you
take to be unfair discrimination in this
case is it just inaccuracy or is it a
relational concept between groups
i
okay i didn't define what and
what soreness is but i'm not in the
abstract for you i don't understand what
you're defining it to be in europe i'm
not defining the notions of fairness
here
because
there are many notions of friends i'm
not trying to define any specific notion
friends but i'm
saying that discrimination could happen
through
an inaccuracy for example if you're
training a predictor
and see it's same
simple very well to the general
population but other fitting for
and
for some
subgroup that is protected
and this could be a form of
unfairness this could be in fact
the the almost the definition
of stereotyping
so it could be that
the model that you're trying to
study would say okay i'm not
because i'm optimizing something overall
i'm trying to i have much more today
from optimizing here than optimizing
there
and therefore i'm going to treat this
entire subpopulation as one and give its
expectation
and this could be and it is a form of
discrimination
and addressing it could um
could be valuable by itself
okay i mean maybe you'll answer this in
the next couple slides i mean of course
let's just stipulate there's multiple
definitions of inference or
discrimination i guess my question is is
that
multiple definitions of alternatives
there's multiple definitions a way of
being of discrimination
yes but so i guess my question is what
what is this the way that you're going
to be concerned i'm not talking about
friends i'm just saying
that's not the topic of the discussion
but i'm happy to discuss it also
and notion
um
that we are using is this multiple
impression that i talked about
and then
it was developed
by herbert jones who came
and it requires some kind of accuracy
compression not only overall
but
for every large
sub-population
and the intuition of how this is related
to the problem that we talked about
of adaptability is that
um
if if the predictor that you come up
with is not only accurate overall
but tries to be accurate for
sub-populations for many sub-populations
then
even in the target distribution
where perhaps some of these
sub-populations are have higher
probability or lower probability
the predictor that we have can be can
still be accurate
so the
statistical
thing we're inferring could still be
correct
okay so
perhaps i'll i'll go quickly through
that
and this is the notion of multi
in fact multi accuracy something that's
weaker than multicalibration that guy
mentioned but it's not the original
notion but
um
a slight strengthening from the work of
michael and others
were we allowing c
to address not a subset but some
function
and
perhaps the definitions and the exact
theorem are less important
but we have this notion of multi
accuracy
and then
when we define the class that we want to
be multi accurate with respect to
through this notion of fantasy scores
then being multi accurate
means that you are universally adaptable
and
i want to talk a little bit
yes exactly so our approach the approach
of the calibration
is kind of very different than the
traditional approach of course
minimization
instead of trying to come up with
something
that minimizes some loss even
optimization is the best in some class
we want something that has some
properties that we can put our hands on
and these properties are
for best understood notions of
indistinguishability want something that
looks like the truth
the two probabilities
for any computation and bounded
adversary this is the notion of outcome
distinguishable that i mentioned
and i mentioned reflecting
so that's a result i just want to
quickly say about
some of the extensions and experiments
that we have
so we said if it's multi-accurate with
respect to this class
then we get that our estimates are
accurate in the target
not only in the
um
yes
so i guess that
i just um
i would i would suspect that if you want
to estimate
the outcomes and the target distribution
and you're using a
pr
or on the x's
i was i was thinking that one might need
an assumption like
uh that for all covariance x
that y conditioned on x
and z equals one is
close to y
condition on x and z equals zero
um which is the assumption we started
with this is the independence assumption
okay okay thank you they i totally just
[Music]
that changes this health condition then
we cannot learn from science or we need
to make some other assumptions
yes absolutely thank you for reminding
these are important
assumptions
so
let me kind of
do a great discussion so i'm going to
scream and
speak to some of the less interesting
things but
as i said you can have
with multi accuracy you can have
a
good estimate at the target for a
particular statistics if you wanted some
more sophisticated statistics we need to
assume a little bit more in the
in the source so instead of just being
multi-accurate with respect to this
class will be multi-calibrated with
respect to a larger class and then we
get that we are also multi-calibrated
and at the target and turns out that
being multi-calibrated at target gives
us
lots of great
properties
in addition there are promising
experiments
about this universal adaptability
uh which and i have some slide at the
end but i won't get to them
and
that
showed that
in practice it seems or at least they're
indicating that this method can actually
work
and it can be comparable and sometimes
even better
than propensity scoring one reason it
could be
better
is that parenthesis current takes one
possible property function into account
and this approach would simultaneously
take all of them into account so if
there is no single propensity score that
that is really capturing the entire
shift in covariances being able to deal
with many of them
is actually a good thing
and
[Music]
what is going for treatment effect very
high level happy to discuss more offline
and so
let's
a
story about the
researchers in israel it's called the
norm that are studying
the effect of vaccinations
towards the severe sicknesses
it's an intervention
now we have somebody
in the u.s
that's called i call them dr fauci they
need to decide whether to take this and
apply to decide policy in the us which
is a different distribution how would
they do that
so it's the same problem that we had
before but
now we're not talking about predictions
but in terms of
a treatment effect
there are two usages of prophetic
scoring here
um
one is simpler we just have the study
that's the story we have the study in
one place we want to adapt it to a
different place
and we use apprentice scoring to kind of
resample
and
and universally the universal
adaptability
works in this setting just as well
the more interesting setting is when we
have distribution on individuals
for which we have intervention
and the intervention and distribution of
individuals for which we don't have the
intervention and they are different
and somehow we want to view it as one
study
the one study we want we would have
liked to have the same distribution
and now the propensity scoring helps
translate
from one distribution to the other
and
and
it turns out that multi calibration
and with some thought can do the same
just want to mention that
you know that multicalibration can also
be used as a way
so here in this work we're talking about
how multicalibration can help you
not do propensity scoring
but it can also give you a way to create
properties scores
with some uh multi-group guarantees this
is a work with
the pylon sharon and leader
let's get to the musings in the
last
three minutes i have
and
so this is
has not been checked
we do it in in at your own risk i'm
actually uh joking because you're
already here so you captured audience so
you can decide not to enter
and
so here is one set so this is very very
vague not formal
and perhaps could be a basis of some
discussion
so
how can non-causality create
discrimination a typical recipe is for
discrimination that you select
a small set of features
that are highly correlated with the
outcome
and these will be the ones on which
you're going to base your decisions
you're going to fit a decision rule
based on these
features
and the fear and the very realistic
theory is that these few decisions
a few variables are a
correlated but the relation is not
causal
and furthermore there are some proxies
for protected
attributes
based on
we're going to treat protected
sets and
unfairly based on that
so that's not an answer for that but one
point about multi-calibration
is that multicalibration allows you to
not
do this stage of first
selecting a few features instead it
allows you to take into account a huge
number of features
and a huge number of decision rules
and potentially if one of these decision
rules
and does capture something in the
causality model
and then then at least we are forcing
our decisions to respect
this decision
rule in some sense so kind of
formalizing what it means and what kind
of
how happy or unhappy we should be with
it is interesting and
in the last uh
slide i want to push a little bit more
on that
um
so again since the
introduction of multicollaboration there
was an explosion of work mostly
still in the world of
applications to
fairness
and
related notions
additional applications additional
algorithms
including things like
how do you use multicalibration for the
sake of more refined affirmative action
but there have been applications beyond
fairness
and
one thing is this outcome
distinguishability which i already
mentioned
which kind of gives a different paradigm
instead of
optimizing for a loss you're trying to
get something that is indistinguishable
from the truth
we have universal adaptability that says
that no matter what the propensity score
is
we are going to do well in estimating
a particular statistics
we have this notion of omni predictors
with pal and kalai sharon and vider
the tenth says
that no matter what is the loss so you
have multi
loss function optimizations
so compared to a class you're going to
do
a
better than
anything in this class
no matter what is the loss function you
care about in a very very general loss
function
so you have ways
using that to say
i don't know what the truth is i don't
know what i care about or will care
about in the future is so i want to do
something that's simultaneously good for
many many different options
the question is
can we have
uh some solution in some context that
says
no matter what is the
causal model that is really
really applies
our solution we take all of these
possible
causal models into account and to do
something that is reasonable in some way
regardless of which one of these cause
and model is the one that we care about
that's kind of a question to discuss and
with that i will end
which variables are responsible
for example what what
what causal graph for example if that's
your method of choice
okay thank you
i am wondering whether we could have a
slightly less strain through and
sometimes when we want to transfer the
nasty outcome with the treatment effect
that
modulate the treatment effect
and then all the providers
[Applause]
yes i think the independence can be
relaxed in several ways but
is there is the rule that applies
still apply
we want to uncover some relation some
rule in the source that would still
apply in the target
and we want i mean this food to exist
otherwise when we learn something in the
source we will
yeah so and i i completely agree that i
think that there are ways of relaxing in
our study in general
i was thinking for example if we say
that the ktp so the conditional average
condition of like conditional to
outcomes to a group riot
in the source is the same
as the target population
these are somehow
less strong assumptions
i don't know just a few
fully
[Music]
yes
is
um
all right let's
take other questions offline and
convert
140 today right
yeah
uh
it was sick yeah it was really sick
everything in more yeah it was it was
uh
wait we're gonna get one